do you think say played a part in
enabling drug cartels and drug
trafficking which is another big kind of
um
shadow that hangs over the cia at the
beginning of the drug war i would
imagine the answer is yes
we cia has its own counter-narcotics
division
a division that's dedicated to fighting
and preventing narcotics from coming
into the united states
so when you when you paint a picture for
me like do you think the cia was
complicit in
in helping drug trafficking or drug use
when i say yes my exception is i don't
think they did that for americans inside
the united states
if the cia can basically set it up so
that two different drug cartels shoot
each other
by
assisting in the transaction of
of
a sale to a third country
and then leaking that that sale happened
to a competing cartel that's just
letting cartels do what they do that's
them doing the dirty work for us so
especially at the beginning of the drug
war i think there was tons of space lots
of room for cia to get involved in the
economics of drugs
and then let the inevitable happen and
that was way more efficient way more
productive than
us trying to send our own troops in to
kill a bunch of cartel warlords so that
makes a ton of sense to me it just seems
efficient it seems very practical i do
not believe that cia would like i don't
think all the accusations out there
about how they would buy drugs and sell
drugs and somehow make money on the side
from it that's not how it works
so do you think there's a
on that point a connection between berry
seal
the great governor and then president
bill clinton oliver north and vice
president former cia director george h.w
bush and the little town with a little
airport called mina arkansas
so i am out of my element now this is
this is one i haven't heard many details
about okay
so
your your senses any other
drug trafficking
has to do with
criminal operations outside the united
states and the cia just leveraging that
to
achieve its ends but nothing to do with
american citizens and american
politicians
uh with american citizens again speaking
organizationally
so that that would be my sense yes
you